can barely speak about what he's
experienced the social worker has been
organizing ambulances for kovic 19
patients and helping families cremate
loved ones who they've lost he was
recently awarded india's fourth highest
civilian honor
social media
i lived the tragedy people witnessed on
tv and social media it was horrendous
one day i cremated 156 bodies we
discovered unclaimed bodies every day
people were that destitute i saw
children bringing the bodies of their
parents
india has recorded the deaths of more
than 500 000 people from kovite covid19
but some health experts say the actual
toll is in the millions
at least half of these occurred last
summer during a surge of infections
fueled by the delta variant overwhelmed
hospitals ran out of oxygen and many
people died as they were waiting to be
admitted
funeral pyres burned across the nation
for days and some families lined up for
hours to cremate their dead in the
northern states of uttar pradesh and
bihar hundreds of bodies were found
floating in the river ganges and buried
by its banks the government denies
claims the death toll is being
underreported india
has used an excessively stringent
definition of what a covet death is and
this leaves no room for
things like
a person who died without a positive
test but with typical symptoms to be
counted as a covert death
several states have recently revised
their tallies
caroline southern india has increased
its death toll the most by 20 000 over
three months
and part of the correction is in
uh being in recognizing
that up to a month after the death
after month after cover admission if the
death is uh linkedin and his ways this
would be eligible to be counted as a
covert death so all of this has actually
resulted in a whole range of
reconciliation of debts and therefore
we see the numbers uh going up in the
recent times which seems a little
artificial
while the numbers of people infected by
the omicron variant have broken records
in many states hospital admissions and
deaths have remained relatively low
experts credit that to milder symptoms
in patients with the variant more than
75 percent of the entire adult
population being fully vaccinated and
most children about 15 being partially
inoculated experts are now asking the
government to expand vaccinations and
boosters to protect people against
future variants pav nimitzira new delhi